They took an offer they couldn’t
refuse and changed cinema forever.
From cryin’ crooners to beloved bodyguards,
these Godfather icons may no longer be
in the family, but their memory lives on.
John Cazale's short-lived but legendary film
career didn't really take off until 1972,
when Francis Ford Coppola cast him as Fredo
Corleone in "The Godfather." As the doomed
middle son of the Corleone family, Cazale's
heartbreaking performance soon became iconic.
"I'm smart! And I want respect!"
After betraying the family in "The
Godfather: Part II," Fredo was tragically
assassinated on the order of his younger
brother, Michael, played by Al Pacino.
"I know it was you, Fredo. You broke my heart."
Perhaps the most interesting thing about Cazale's
films apart from "The Godfather" and its first
sequel is that each of the three projects had a
major connection to the "The Godfather" films.
1974's "The Conversation" was also
directed by Coppola, while the 1975
crime drama "Dog Day Afternoon"
reunited Cazale with Pacino.
In his final screen role,
1978's Best Picture Oscar
winner "The Deer Hunter," Cazale
starred opposite Robert De Niro,
who portrayed the young Vito Corleone so
memorably in "The Godfather: Part II."
Tragically, Cazale's eleven-year battle
with lung cancer ended on March 13,
1978, with his girlfriend "Deer Hunter" co-star
Meryl Streep, by his side. Aware of his terminal
illness during the production, director Michael
Cimino reportedly rearranged the shooting order
of the film so Cazale could complete his scenes.
Unfortunately, Cazale never got the opportunity
to celebrate the release of "The Deer Hunter." The
film premiered in Los Angeles in December of 1978,
nine months after his tragically
premature death at the age of 42.
Unlike many of the bodyguards who protected the
Corleone family, Richard Bright's character,
Al Neri, survived all three "Godfather" films.
"The old dons were pretty much wiped out. The
ones that survived made a deal with Joey Zaza."
Bright had a prolific career that
goes all the way back to 1957,
when he first began appearing in films,
television shows, and stage plays. Notably,
in 1971 he played Al Pacino's character's brother,
Hank, in "The Panic in Needle Park" and in 1972,
played "The Thief" alongside Steve
Mcqueen and Ali McGraw in "The Getaway."
Apart from playing Neri in all three "Godfather"
films, the steely-eyed actor alternated between
bad guy and good guy roles in a variety of films,
including "Marathon Man," "Red Heat," and "Once
Upon a Time in America." He also appeared
in a string of television series, including
the prison drama "Oz," the iconic mafia series
"The Sopranos," and the "Law & Order" franchise.
Bright died in a tragic accident at the age of
68. On February 18, 2006, while crossing a street
on New York's Upper West Side, he was hit and
killed by a bus. Fourteen years after his death,
Bright's contribution to "The Godfather"
saga was honored once more with Coppola's
redux of the third "Godfather" film, a re-edited
version retitled "The Godfather, Coda: The Death
of Michael Corleone." The third chapter features
more of Al Neri than any other "Godfather" film,
as Neri has escalated in the ranks to become a
close confidant of Michael and Connie Corleone.
Singer-turned-actor Al Martino played Johnny
Fontane, the silky-voiced crooner looking
for his big break in motion pictures in
the first chapter of "The Godfather."
"Johnny, Johnny, cantare
una canzone, sing a song!"
In one memorable early scene, while pleading his
case to Marlon Brando's Vito Corleone, crying
about how he missed out on a role in a film, the
weepy Fontane is slapped by the incensed Don Vito.
"You can act like a man! Whatsa matter with you?"
And, spoiler alert — Johnny got the role after a
studio executive was forced to accept an offer he,
well… really couldn't refuse! In real life,
Martino stuck to his successful career as a
singer, scoring a slew of hits over the years.
While he's most well-known for the song "Spanish
Eyes," other hits include: "Here in My Heart," and
"I Love You Because." His songs also appeared on
movie soundtracks, most notably as the title track
of the eerie Bette Davis thriller "Hush...Hush,
Sweet Charlotte." Naturally, Martino's
songs were featured on the soundtracks
of "The Godfather" and "The Godfather: Part
III," where he reprised the role of Fontane.
Martino was 82 years old when he died of a heart
attack in Pennsylvania on October 13, 2009.
While some actors only appeared in a scene or
two in "The Godfather" trilogy, they still become
etched in the minds of movie fans. Perhaps the
most memorable of these supporting players?
John Marley, who played defiant studio
executive Jack Woltz in the first film.
Woltz appeared in two notable scenes in the film,
where Vito Corleone's adopted son, Tom Hagen,
played by Robert Duvall, arrived in Hollywood
with an offer the studio head couldn't refuse:
cast Johnny Fontane in his new film…
or else. Woltz blasted Hagen's offer,
only to wake up the next morning
with the bloodied head of his prize
stallion tucked into bed with him. Not
surprisingly Fontane landed the role.
Marley was a prolific actor, having amassed
more than 170 film and television credits
over his 35-year career. His appearance
as Ali McGraw's father in "Love Story"
was a particular highlight, earning him
a Best Supporting Actor Oscar nomination.
"Now, don't talk like that Oliver. A father's
love is something to cherish and respect.
It's a rare thing."
Marley had roles in several television series,
including "Hawaii Five-0" and "The Twilight Zone."
The actor died after open heart surgery
on May 22, 1984. He was 76 years old.
Like John Marley's Jack Woltz, the appearance
of Lenny Montana's Luca Brasi is brief, but
memorable. Brasi, Don Vito Corleone's deadliest
assassin, first appears in the film rehearsing
his speech and then presenting a gift to the Don
for his daughter, Connie, on her wedding day.
"Who is he, what's his name?"
"His name is Luca Brasi. He
helps my father out sometimes."
Later, Brasi is stabbed and garroted in a
vicious scene on the orders of Corleone foe
Virgil Sollozzo, played by Al Lettieri.
After Brasi's death, Sollozzo delivers
a message to the Corleone family that their
fearsome henchman "sleeps with the fishes."
"The Godfather" was actually Montana's first
credited film role. Born Lenny Passaforo,
he made his living as a professional wrestler,
going under the name Lenny "The Bull" Montana
in the 1950s and '60s. Keeping the Montana
moniker for his film career, the 6-foot,
6-inch actor's powerful physique not only came in
handy for landing his role in "The Godfather," but
other films that required a heavy, acting with
Harvey Keitel in "Fingers," and Jackie Chan in
"Battle Creek Brawl." Montana died of a heart
attack on May 12, 1992. He was 66 years old.
Abe Vigoda became best known
as Detective Phil Fish on the
classic cop sitcom "Barney Miller" and
later on his own spinoff series, "Fish."
But the actor first made a splash a
few years earlier as Salvatore Tessio,
a high-ranking member of the Corleone family
who delivered an iconic line in "The Godfather."
During a meeting with Michael Corleone, Sonny
Corleone, and Tom Hagen, Tessio enters the room
with a bullet proof vest wrapped in brown paper.
The package contains, famously, a dead fish.
"That's a Sicilian message. It means
Luca Brassi sleeps with the fishes."
When Tessio betrays the family and finds himself
facing a similar fate, he begs for mercy:
"Tom, can you get me off the
hook? For old times' sake?"
Like many of his fellow "Godfather"
actors, Vigoda had a prolific career
with nearly 100 roles to his name. They
included early television appearances
on such series as "Barney Miller,"
"Dark Shadows," and "The Love Boat."
Vigoda's film work included "Joe Versus the
Volcano" and "Good Burger." He was also a
favorite and frequent guest on "Late Night With
Conan O'Brien." Vigoda, who outlasted persistent
rumors of his death, passed away from natural
causes on January 26, 2016. He was 94 years old.
Like many of his castmates, Richard
S. Castellano rose to prominence after
appearing in the first "Godfather." Before being
cast as Corleone family captain Peter Clemenza,
Castellano had appeared in about a dozen film
and television productions. Clemenza became
famous for uttering these six classic words,
which Castellano says he partly improvised:
"Leave the gun. Take the cannoli."
Castellano, who only appeared in the first
"Godfather" film, worked steadily afterwards,
mostly in television. His credits included
the lead role in the sitcom "The Super,"
where he played a building superintendent. He
took another lead as Joe Vitale in the sitcom
"Joe and Sons," and appeared as a crime heavy once
more in the mini-series "The Gangster Chronicles."
Castellano died on December 10, 1988,
after suffering a heart attack. He was 55.
While Bruno Kirby is predominantly known
for his comedic work in such films as
"When Harry Met Sally," "City Slickers,"
and "This is Spinal Tap”, his early work
also included a dramatic turn as the young
Peter Clemenza in "The Godfather Part II."
Francis Ford Coppola and Mario Puzo took the
first "Godfather" sequel in a different direction,
as the film's narrative hopped back and forth
between the past and the present to recount the
rise of Robert DeNiro's young Vito Corleone before
he became a don in New York's criminal underworld.
Kirby's career was well underway before he
portrayed the young Clemenza. His credits
included the short-lived sitcom "The Super," where
he played one of Richard S. Castellano's sons.
Kirby would go on to claim an impressive
70 screen credits in his 35-year career,
including roles opposite Marlon Brando and Matthew
Broderick in the mob comedy "The Freshman."
"Tragically, I suffer from a gambling problem."
Kirby played opposite another "Godfather"
alum, Al Pacino, in "Donnie Brasco." He also
worked with Garry Shandling on both "It's Garry
Shandling's Show" and "The Larry Sanders Show."
Kirby's life and career were
cut short on August 14, 2006,
when he passed away due to complications
from leukemia at the age of 57.
Michael V. Gazzo's Frank Pentangeli
was a major figure in "The Godfather,
Part II," as the Corleone family caporegime
who replaced Peter Clemenza and ran the
family's operations in New York City while
Michael Corleone relocated to Las Vegas.
"Hey, what's with the food around
here? Kid comes up to me in a white
jacket gives me a Ritz cracker with
chopped liver and he says canapes."
Eventually, in an effort to save his own hide,
Pentangeli began cooperating with the U.S.
government and was prepared to turn on Michael and
testify against him before a U.S. Senate panel.
He ultimately recanted his story and took his
own life to preserve the Sicilian code of honor.
Like the first "Godfather" film, the sequel
yielded more than one Best Supporting Actor
nomination. This time, it pitted Gazzo
against legendary acting coach Lee Strasberg,
who played Corleone family investor
Hyman Roth, as well as Robert De Niro,
who ended up winning for his portrayal of
a young Vito Corleone. Despite his loss,
Gazzo's 1974 Oscar nom still gave him a
major career boost. He went on to appear
in the mob comedy "Cookie," the crime drama
"Fingers," and the 1977 thriller "Black Sunday."
Gazzo also booked dozens of guest roles on
popular television shows, including "Taxi."
Before his acting career, Gazzo was
known as a respected playwright,
penning the 1955 classic "A Hatful of Rain,"
later turned into an Oscar-nominated film.
Gazzo died on February 14, 1995, at the
age of 71, after suffering a stroke.
Stage director Lee Strasberg has long been
celebrated in Hollywood for his work as a
legendary acting coach, both at his Actor's Studio
in New York City and at the Actor's Studio West
in Los Angeles. He had a great number of famous
students including Marilyn Monroe, Paul Newman,
and James Dean, along with "Godfather" stars
Marlon Brando, Al Pacino and Robert De Niro.
Strasberg's role as Corleone family
investor and business partner Hyman Roth,
who eventually betrays Michael Corleone, marked
a rare step away from his work as an educator.
"And I said to myself - this
is the business we've chosen!"
It was only appropriate that the man who taught
so many legendary actors be nominated for an Oscar
himself, which came in the Best Supporting
Actor category. Strasberg was nominated
opposite fellow "Godfather, Part II"
stars Michael V. Gazzo and Robert De
Niro. De Niro ended up winning the prize
for his portrayal of young Vito Corleone.
Post "Godfather," Strasberg
popped up in a few more films,
notably the legal drama "And Justice
for All" opposite Pacino and the crime
comedy "Going in Style," with
George Burns and Art Carney.
But Strasberg's true passion was always teaching
– which he continued to do at the Actor's Studio,
where he remained until his death from a heart
attack on February 17, 1982. He was 80 years old.
Even a powerful U.S. politician was no match
for Don Michael Corleone in "The Godfather:
Part II," at least as G.D. Spradlin's
character, Senator Pat Geary,
painfully discovered. Spradlin perfectly
embodied a corrupt politician in the film,
playing a man who tried to extort a large sum of
money from Michael, including monthly personal
payouts, as the Corleone family tried
to expand its Las Vegas hotel operation.
"I despise your masquerade. The
dishonest way you pose yourself."
Pressing Michael and the family
further with U.S. Senate hearings,
Geary eventually found himself
in a compromising position,
a strong signal that the Corleones are the only
people who can make offers you can't refuse.
A lawyer-turned-oil-producer before finding his
calling in acting, Spradlin started off his career
with a string of guest turns on such television
series as "I Spy" and "Bonanza." After his role
as the slimy Pat Geary in "The Godfather: Part
II," Spradlin enjoyed a long career in film.
Some of his features included "North Dallas Forty"
and "Ed Wood," with Bill Murray and Johnny Depp.
Notably, Spradlin worked with "The Godfather"
director Francis Ford Coppola a second time,
playing General Corman in the
acclaimed film "Apocalypse Now."
"Spradlin's final role came in 1999,
when he played legendary Washington
Post executive editor Ben Bradlee in the
political comedy spoof "Dick," alongside
Will Ferrell, Kirsten Dunst and Michelle Williams.
"You're talking about the man who controls
access to the leader of the free world."
Spradlin died of natural causes
at age 90 on July 24, 2011.
Legendary actor Eli Wallach didn't join "The
Godfather" saga until the third film in 1990,
bringing decades of movie and television
experience to the role of Don Osvaldo Altobello.
The wily Altobello seems to be an ally of Michael
Corleone in the film, at least until the exposure
of his betrayal, leading to his poisoning at the
opera house during the film's extended climax.
"You're not telling me the whole truth, Vincenzo."
Wallach compiled an amazing 172 credits
over his 60-year career and was honored
for his television work with five Primetime
Emmy Award nominations. The first in 1967
resulted in a win for Outstanding Supporting
Actor in a Drama for "The Poppy Is Also a
Flower," with the last nod coming in 2010
for Outstanding Guest Actor in a Comedy
Series for "Nurse Jackie." While it took
six decades, Wallach was finally honored
with the ultimate prize — an honorary
Oscar for Lifetime Achievement — in 2011.
The actor's impressive film resume included
memorable turns in such features as the legendary
western "The Magnificent Seven" — where he starred
alongside Yul Brynner, Steve McQueen, and James
Coburn — and director Sergio Leone's iconic "The
Good, the Bad, and the Ugly," playing opposite
Clint Eastwood. He also appeared alongside
Marilyn Monroe in her last film, "The Misfits."
"Well tell me. He doesn't know what
you're all about. He'll never know."
Wallach's last feature film role was in
the 2010 "Wall Street" sequel "Wall Street:
Money Never Sleeps." The actor died on June
24, 2014, at age 98, of natural causes.
Perhaps no "Godfather" movie death is more painful
to watch than that of Alex Rocco's Moe Greene,
the volatile, gravel-voiced Las Vegas
casino owner who roughs up Fredo Corleone.
"Do you know who I am? I'm Moe Greene! I made my
bones when you were going out with cheerleaders!"
Greene's harsh treatment of Michael's
brother naturally gets to Michael. This,
along with the fact that Greene is unwilling
to sell his casinos to the family, results in
one of the most vivid assassinations
in the trilogy. Moe is shot through
the eye while getting a massage during the
climactic bloodbath in the film's third act.
Greene's death is significant, as it is implied
in "The Godfather, Part II" that Hyman Rothis
driven by the death of his childhood friend
and business partner to destroy Michael.
"That kid's name was Moe Green."
With less than a dozen film and TV roles
to his credit, Rocco's career took off
after his menacing portrayal of Greene.
Like his career before "The Godfather,"
the actor's work alternated between film
and television, but at a much busier pace.
On television, Rocco guest-starred on such series
as "The Golden Girls" and "The Facts of Life."
"Wait, where did you ever get the
idea that we were getting married?"
Later, he had a role on "The George Carlin
Show, " playing George's best friend,
the ex-con Harry Rossetti. Rocco won a primetime
Emmy in 1990 for Outstanding Supporting Actor
in a comedy series for his role as
Al Floss in "The Famous Teddy Z."
On film, Rocco appeared in "Cannonball
Run II," a seemingly popular destination
for "Godfather" alumni, and played
gangster Jimmy Capp in "Get Shorty!",
which made reference to his unforgettable death
in "The Godfather." He also appeared in "Dream
a Little Dream," "The Wedding Planner,"
and as the boisterous record executive
Sol Siler in Tom Hanks' directorial
debut, "That Thing You Do!"
"It is jammed - jammed with kids! And why?
Why? I'll tell ya why. These Wonders
are playing music like nectar!!"
Rocco died from pancreatic cancer
on July 18, 2015 at age 79.
Virgil Sollozzo was a character living
on borrowed time in "The Godfather," and
Al Lettieri was the actor who gave Sollozzo
such an intense, menacing presence.
"No more attempts on my father's life."
"What guarantees can I give
you Mike? I'm the hunted one!"
The arrival of Sollozzo, a heroin kingpin, marked
a sea change in the criminal underworld of New
York City, where Don Vito Corleone had advised the
five crime families to rebuke the drug business.
Things came to a head when Sollozzo had a hand in
killing Vito's bodyguard Luca Brasi, and tried but
failed to assassinate Vito, leading Michael to
commit his first murder on behalf of the family.
"Do you know who I am?"
Prior to "The Godfather," Lettieri's
career was full of television appearances,
including guest roles on such classics
as "Perry Mason" and "Gunsmoke."
Like many of his "Godfather" acting counterparts,
Lettieri's film opportunities expanded greatly
after his exposure in the film, landing him in
such features as "The Getaway" with Steve McQueen,
"McQ" opposite John Wayne, and "Mr.
Majestyk," starring Charles Bronson.
Sadly, Lettieri's career was cut short when
he died of a heart attack on October 18,
1975. He was just 47 years old.
Michael Corleone passes the point of no return
in "The Godfather" when he assassinates family
rival Virgil Sollozzo. But sitting right
there with him — and becoming Michael's
second victim— is Captain Mark McCluskey,
played by Hollywood legend Sterling Hayden.
"Stand him up! Stand him up straight!"
McCluskey is a corrupt police official
who doubles as an ad hoc bodyguard of
Sollozzo while also taking bribes from
the Tattaglia family. Michael proposes
to execute both Sollozzo and McCluskey after
a failed attempt on Don Vito Corleone's life.
The public execution of the pair at a
public restaurant is brief, but brutal.
"How's the Italian Food in this restaurant?"
Hayden was already a bona fide film star
by the time he was cast in "The Godfather,"
with more than four dozen roles to his credit,
including John Huston's "The Asphalt Jungle,"
and "Johnny Guitar." Hayden also appeared
in two acclaimed Stanley Kubrick films:
"The Killing," and "Doctor Strangelove or: How
I Learned to Stop Worrying and Love the Bomb."
"Total commitment"
The towering Hayden, who
stood at 6-feet 5-inches tall,
relaxed his pace a bit after "The
Godfather." He still worked, though,
starring in lighter fare like the
classic workplace comedy "9 to 5."
After a battle with cancer, Hayden
died on May 23, 1986. at the age of 70.
Fans of "The Godfather" are quite
familiar with Carmela Corelone,
played by Morgana King. Also known as Mama
Corleone, Carmela is mother to Sonny, Fredo,
Michael, and Connie Corleone, as well
as the adoptive mother of Tom Hagen.
And even though she only has a few lines, it's
clear this is a woman who puts her family first.
"You go see your children first. And then you
worry about waiting on line to see your brother.
Like everybody else."
She's also the wife of Don Vito Corleone,
and suffers through the execution of Sonny
and the death of Vito after his sudden heart
attack. On a more positive note, she will
always be remembered for her singing at Connie's
wedding reception. This made sense, seeing as
how King was a professional singer who had an
impressive four-octave contralto vocal range.
Aside from reprising her role as
Mama Corleone for "The Godfather,
Part II," King only had a handful of
screen credits on both film and television,
most notably in a recurring role on the classic
daytime soap "All My Children" in 1993. Her
last screen appearance came in 1997 in the Danny
Aiello crime drama, "A Brooklyn State of Mind."
King died from non-Hodgkin's lymphoma
on March 22, 2018 at the age of 87.
The death of Marlon Brando in 2004 was a loss
for fans of classic cinema and the "Godfather"
series alike. A truly legendary presence,
Brando's storied film career began with his
star-making appearances in films like "On The
Waterfront" and "A Streetcar Named Desire."
"Hey Stella!"
What's interesting about Brando's turn as Don Vito
Corleone is that while he was already an iconic,
Oscar-nominated actor, his career in Hollywood
was actually on a bit of a downslide. In fact,
director Francis Ford Coppola had to fight to get
the actor cast after a string of box office bombs.
It finally happened, but only under strict
conditions set out by Paramount Pictures,
including a screen test — quite
unprecedented for such an esteemed actor.
The 47-year-old Brando's transformation into
the much older Don Vito was not lost on fans,
critics and the film industry.
It earned him his second Best
Actor Oscar and revitalized his career.
Brando went to other acclaimed roles,
including Kal-El's father, Jor-El, in director
Richard Donner's "Superman," and the crazed,
reclusive Colonel Kurtz in Coppola's
Vietnam War classic "Apocalypse Now."
Even though Brando famously spurned his
Best Actor Oscar for "The Godfather" to
protest the treatment of Native Americans,
the Motion Picture Academy rewarded him
one last time with a Best Supporting Actor
nomination for the 1989 anti-apartheid drama,
"A Dry White Season." Other notable roles
followed, including the 2005 comedy-drama
"Don Juan DeMarco" and the troubled 1996
remake of "The Island of Dr. Moreau."
"Look at yourself!"
"I understand that I must be shocking to you."
Brando's final feature film appearance came
opposite Robert De Niro and Edward Norton in the
2001 heist thriller "The Score." The legendary
actor died three years later on July 1, 2004,
at age 80 from pulmonary fibrosis — leaving behind
one of the greatest legacies in film history.
Fans of "The Godfather" trilogy know
that Sonny Corleone — played by James
Caan in the first two films — had a legendary
reputation among all of the mafia families as
heir to the Corleone empire — and
as a guy with a serious temper.
"Hey come on knock it off!"
"Sonny!"
"Punk."
Furthering their war with the other Five Families,
Sonny gets on the last nerve of Emilio Barzini,
who sets a trap for the hot-headed Corleone heir.
Sonny is brutally killed on the causeway, leaving
his brother Michael to finish the war he started
and turn the Corleones into the most powerful
crime family ever known. At the end of "Part
III," Sonny's illegitimate son Vincent, played
by Andy Garcia, takes over the empire, something
which certainly would've made his father proud.
“What did he say? Bada beep bada bap bada boop. He
wants us to send Michael to hear the proposition.
And the promise is that the deal
is so good that we can't refuse."
Although Sonny's life was cut short,
actor James Caan had an incredibly long
and successful career spanning nearly 60
years, with hits in almost every decade.
Though his most recognizable work might
be as Sonny, Caan also had starring roles
in many other major films, including
Michael Maan's "Thief," Rob Reiner's
"Misery," Francis Ford Coppola's "Gardens of
Stone," and Wes Anderson's "Bottle Rocket."
"I'm-a tell you something kid -
you got the guts of a damn lion."
But perhaps Caan's most famous performance outside
of "The Godfather" is also the most unlikely one:
his comedic turn as Will Ferrell's father in
"Elf." Cann's portrayal of children's book
publisher Walter Hobbes in Jon Favreau's Christmas
classic brought him a whole new legion of fans.
Sadly, the actor died on July 6, 2022, and
the film industry would never be the same.